but
[Música
] informs héctor mejía with his brief
informative nevada legislators have
finished their second session but
not before approving a
controversial bill which blocks
people from suing businesses if they
contract the kobe 19 sb4 virus was
approved by the assembly before
midnight is now in
the governor's office sticks is now
this project is supported by the
auto industry and the
culinary union includes protecting their
workers and emphasizes the importance
of cleanliness measures within these
properties as well  protect
businesses from being sued for
the virus state gaming control board
filed suit
against one of the largest viewers
of las vegas script
this has to do with the pandemic
cgr las vegas' is  accused of violating the
security measures established
during the month of June and July, one of
these consisted of a meeting of more than  e
people the other two were because
several people crowded
around slot machines or gaming tables
without gambling on the other
hand bars that serve food
can also offer their customers the use
of slot machines again yesterday
the clark county commission  approved a
measure that allows bars and
canteens to have machines distanced
from each other
these will replace those that are
usually found in the bars since
people cannot sit in them
during the pandemic for the moment the
bars can have up to 15  machines
available and now we move on to
the weather forecast today thursday we will see
a drop in temperatures but
we will still be above 100 degrees
a clear sky is expected with some
breezes for the afternoon have a great
day I am hector mejía and this was your
brief  Spanish ginseng informative
[Music]